[Music]
what is he wearing
they found matthew standing on the
landing of the second floor
matthew was looking down at the
officer's positioned blocking the top
come down here
all right dude
just come down here so we can talk
you're not going to jail why would you
be going to jail
huh
all right you just tuck those real quick
you're not going to go to jail man
huh you can hear me as officers were
talking with matthew they attempted to
walk up the stairs
concerned for their safety officers
stayed on the middle landing of the
stairs they continued talking with
matthew and offering him help
matthew told officers he wasn't coming
down and that he would not let them up
huh
i'm not coming up i ain't going down
dude
all right what's what's the issue today
how can we help you
today don't worry about it well i have
to because now i'm over here i need you
to move over so i can come up
i'm not coming okay if you move that way
we can go up yeah
you're trying to fight is that what
you're trying to do
you're trying to die
at about 10 31 a.m matthew is heard
saying he was trying to die
shortly after he is seen removing a
knife from his right pants pocket he
begins to take a step down the stairs
towards officers drop it he has a knife
officers ordered matthew to drop the
knife drop it
dude
if you don't drop right now i'm going to
shoot you
all right
if you take one step
here's the same event from a different
officer's body
you